こんにちは
私は
岩手から今日来ましたので多少
治外法権を認めてもらえればいいなと思い
ますのでちょっと発言に出現があるかも
しれませんがよろしくお願いします
今紹介に預かった岩間なんですけども僕は
馬方っていう仕事をしています
馬方って皆さん何だって思うかと思います
けども
馬を使って
農業林業をすることの上手かったってい
ます
馬方の
先月9月18日の様子がこの
画像です
皆さん見てで
馬車があって見ての通り
凱旋門なのでパリに行ってました
なんで
馬形がパリにこんなとこに
馬車に乗ってこういうことできてるんだっ
て言うと皆さん非常に謎に思われると思う
んですけども
でもこの馬方をやることによって僕は結構
ヨーロッパだったり世界アフリカにも行っ
てますそんな話も今日できたらいいなと
思ってできたらいいなとか話をするんです
けども
ちなみに僕は全然ボンボンでもないしお
金持ちでもないからこの
凱旋門シャンデリア通りを他社で走ると
いうのは多少お金かかりますでもそんな
あのことがこの僕がね馬方っていうことを
やっててできるというなんでそんなことが
本当できるんだっていうことを皆さん思う
と思いますねでこの馬車をあの
操縦
描写をしているのは僕ですねこので日の丸
の旗を
立ててこの企画はルートはポーラゾンって
言って
ブローニューっていうドーバー海峡の街
から
パリまで
昔お魚を馬車で運んでたそれをモチーフに
した
魚運び馬車レースなんですねその全ての
レースに参加しようと思うと
馬20頭とあと人40人ぐらいのチーム
作らなきゃいけないんでさすがに全部は
出れないので
一部特に一部はそのパリの中の
レースの一部に参加させてもらえ
るっていうであとはその
馬が集まったら今さっき言ったその僕が
バーンて馬で林業する実はそのヨーロッパ
には
馬鹿の競技会もありますそこにも参加して
いましたで他社にこの日本のヒノマロを
建ててこうやって参加したと
でそのせっかくも僕があのそのマクロン
大統領を率いるそのルートはポアソンの
教会の方から招待をいただいたんですけど
もその時に
せっかくだから日本の馬耳文化も持ってっ
て
シャンゼリどおりを歩いたら面白いなあと
思って僕はその岩手出身なのでやっぱり
岩手で
馬事文化
馬のことで言うと
チャグチャグマッコっていう今ねこの画像
に映っている馬に衣装をつけて歩くこれを
持って行ったら非常に
鮮やかだし向こうのフランス人も喜ぶ
だろうなと思って先月そういう企画を立て
てチャゲが同好会の方にも来てもらって
シャンゼリー
草履を歩いて思いました何でパリに
シャンデリアのこの学校を持っていく
かって皆さん不思議に思うかもしれません
けど実はあのこれ
ちょっと前に出しますこれあの岩手の本来
その6月第2土曜日にやっている学校の
風景なんですけども
こういう形で歩いてますこれは
実はこの今見てる画像の馬もフランスの馬
もほとんど同じですなぜ同じかっていうと
今から134年前に
フランスから大きな馬特にペルシロンって
いうのが
導入されてきましたでその導入されてきた
馬が日本の
農林業にどんどん入っていって日本の和地
文化に浸透していきましたそして
衣装をつけてチャグチャがうまくこって
いうお祭りが
岩手で行われていますでその形を
逆に逆輸入してフランスの人たちに見て
もらうとそういうので実はそこのフランス
にいる馬に衣装ももちろんあります日本で
使ってる馬も
ルーツはフランスなので
進めます
なので実はその馬の関係性つながりがあ
るって事ですねだから闇雲にあの馬耳文化
を持ってってるわけではないんですねで今
この今僕と僕の師匠今81歳なんですけど
も三方さんて言うんですけども実は美香
さんもこういう大きな馬を使ってずっと
馬で山で仕事していきましたで三河さん
その大きな馬これはちょっとベルジャン系
が入ってるんですが大きな松飼っている
から見方さんの僕の師匠の
夢というかはフランスに行ってみたいと
本場フランスのペルシロンブルトンとか
大きな馬を見たいっていうので三川さんが
ずっと
夢を抱いてたのに今回一緒にどうこうして
もらってフランスに来てこの三河さんが
本当凱旋門の前に立って記念
撮影したんですけどもこれ僕が取った写真
なんですけどもこの凱旋門の門とこの
ホッカムリの
角度とものすごいなんかリンクしているの
が皆さん分かり
ですかね実はこのほっかむりしているのっ
て
ヨーロッパで有名なのは先月
亡くなられましたけどエリザベス女王も
意外とスカーフでねこっから無理してたり
するんですよだからヨーロッパで北海道に
しているのエリザベス女王とこの美方さん
しかも豆の豆絞りというこのシュールな
写真をちょっと僕が撮ってたまにいい写真
撮るなって僕でも思ってるんですけど
こんな感じでいい写真撮れたなと
で今この田んぼの絵なんですけどもさっき
言った
箱
蛇行って何かって言うと馬で土を耕すん
ですね
で60年70年前は日本全国どこでも
馬牛を使って
田畑を耕すというのはものすごい普通でし
た当たり前もちろん機会がないんで
機会がなければどうするかっていうとクワ
ですよね人力であるでも
倫理系ってやっぱ大変なので
昔の人ってがそのちょっと前の人どうし
たかっていうと
築力
馬や牛を使うってことをやってましたで僕
は今その
馬で耕して土を耕して全てやってお米を
作ってそれでお酒を作るということもやっ
てます
で今回行ったその
凱旋門の前からシャンゼリゼ通りを通り
エリーゼキューの大統領官邸のところに
行って大統領
官邸の料理人の方にお酒を
渡すこともできたしあとは一応お酒をね
マクロン大統領に飲んでもらいたいって
いう思いで飲んだかどうか分かりません
けどとりあえず手渡したのであとは飲んで
もらえたらいいなと
思いますねでなぜ
こうやってこの馬方ほとんどの人が知ら
ない
馬方という職業をして
ヨーロッパにこうやって行けるか
ものすごい不思議だと思うんですねそれは
実は
僕がその2011年にこの
馬方っていう
バハン箱をすることによって
未来はあるかなとそのままやってても当然
皆さんが知らないようにこれはもう完全に
廃れてきたもうなくなろうとしていること
だったので何とかしてその
価値を出していきたいなと思って
考えた時に日本では評価されないけど実は
ヨーロッパに行ったらやってる人いるし
評価してくれる国に行って行ったらまあ何
かいいことあるかなそれで実は僕はあの
2011年にイギリスに行きました
でイギリスの
ブリティッシュフォースロガーズってバハ
協会がありまして実はその
販協会の
会長トップがチャールズ皇太子がその時
やってたんですねでそこに行ってそして
あの行ったら大会も出してくれるよとあと
はその会議も出してあげるって言って非常
に本当にどこの馬の骨かわからないのに
そうやってあのウェルカムで
招待してくれたんですね
でその大会があるって言われて僕はもう
てっきり馬車のレースでバハンの大会って
あるっていう全然知らなかったんで
だけどね
イケてるからそしたら本当に馬鹿の大会が
あってやったことなかったんですけども
ちょっとやってみたらその時ちょっと
100万ぐらい借金して飛行機代とか
諸々やってたんで帰りをお土産買うお金
なかったんで
3位ぐらいに入ったら土産話になるなと
思って少しは頑張ろうと思って
頑張ったんですねで
やったことなかったけど見てそれを真似し
て
頑張ったらなんかうまくできるなあとは
やってるうちに向こうの人達ってうまく
できると拍手してくれるんですね
拍手してくれるから非常にこれは何か
気持ちがいいなと普段の仕事終わって周り
に人いないんですよ
まあたまにクマが走ってね下を歩いてたな
とか
鹿が横切ったなみたいなそういう世界だっ
たんですね誰も見に来ないしそんな世界で
やってるんで人が周りにいて
拍手してくれるっていう環境がものすごい
いいもんだなと思ってそれでよし頑張ろう
と思ってやったらばもうまさにビギナー
ドラッグでそこで優勝できたんですねで
その優勝できたことによって何が起こっ
たかっていうとどんどんチャンスをもらっ
て次は
ヨーロッパチャンピオンシップ出ていいよ
と
ヨーロッパチャンピオンシップ出れば
ヨーロッパ各国から来るのでまたそこから
ネットワークで次はフランスに来ないかと
かそういう感じでどんどん実はそのまあ
冒険というかチャレンジしたことによって
チャンスをさらにいただくことができて
また今回の
馬車レース
来ないかっていうお誘いをいただいて実は
どんどんどんどんそうやってあの
チャンスをいただくことができたんですね
だからその日本にとどまらずに世界行くと
結構いいことあるなとでこの60っていう
数字ちょっといきなり出しましたけど実は
これは役なんですけども人口80億ぐらい
はいますで機械にアクセスしている人達
って実は20億人ぐらいその他の60億約
60年近い人達ってか地区力の
農業やってるんですね
でそれでその今セネガルに行ったりもする
んですけどそういうアフリカの人たちに
日本の実は素晴らしい
農機具道具を紹介したりしています
これは担保でちょっと遊んでるシーンなん
ですけど
画像はないですね
なのでそのアフリカに行くともう馬を使っ
て馬とかロバとか使ってる人たちが
たくさんいます
だから今日本でこの地区力馬を使うって
いうのは非常に何だろう
珍しい
珍しいけど実は日本もたくさんやってたし
素晴らしい道具があると
そういう国なんですねそこで僕ちょっと
頑張って
頑張ってというか面白いからやってるん
ですけどもそうやっているとどんどん
どんどん世界が広がっていきました
実は今日はこの大学の
芸大の学生たち僕のファッション
チェックをしてもらったんですけどなんで
そんな赤いネクタイしてるんだとこれ
エルメスなんですね
そんな似合わないものをして
なんでエルメスかって言うと僕のその農業
林業のコンセプトはエルメス農業エルメス
林業なんですよ
そうやってどんどん価値を書いていこうと
だから今回も僕はあのパリのエルメスの
本店もこの場所で行ったんですよ
そことってエリー級
コンコルド広場通ってまだ混ざってくる
みたいなそんなあの
遊びもしたりして
非常に実はその馬っていうのは世界に
ものすごい実は通用するツールというか
ものなんですねそういう素晴らしいものを
どんどん広げていくで広げ方としてはお酒
も作るしいろんなその今の人形もやって
いるから馬で出した木材で建物も建てる
そんなことをどんどんやってます
治外法権をちょっと許してくださいって
言ったんですけど僕あのバハンっていうの
をやってるんでバハンっていうのは馬で
林業丸太を引き出すことを言うんですけど
阪南で
京都のイメージで
京都でハンがつくものって何かなって思う
と
舞妓さんですよね
であのマイク版が多分年取るとすごい偉く
なると僕はおばはんになると思ってたん
ですよ
これ大阪じゃないから言ってもいいと思い
ますけどよくよくみんなに聞いたら何を
言ってんだってよく言われるから多分ご
法度だろうなとまあでも治外法権なんで
おばさん僕の最大のライバルになるおば
さんと手を組んで
その林業をやっていって日本の山をよく
しようと
だからそういう
[音楽]
判定皆さん多分見たことないと思うんです
けども今度なんかちょっとテレビの依頼も
あるからちょっともう少しちょっと
メディアに出て行こうかなと思うので
どんどんどんどん目にする機会が増えて
くるかなと思いますんで実はこの日本の
こういう里山とか見ている山のところで
実はちょっと前までは馬飼をしっかり
引き出していたんですねそうすると要は
地形はいじらないので
環境自然地形はそのままでいけるとだから
すごい実は林業の中でもメリットがあり
ます
で実は今若い人たちもどんどんやりたいっ
ていう人たちが出てきているので
来年にはその働く馬の学校みたいなものを
作ってどんどん人が増えていけばいいかな
とそういうふうに思っています今日は
ちょっと笑いが取れなかったんでこれで
首を吊って反省します
失礼しました
[拍手]